- WHOA.
- MAN, I FELT SORRY
FOR THAT DUDE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT YOU GONNA DO?
I HAD TO LAY
THAT [bleep] DOWN.
[laughter]
YOU KNOW I DID, DOG.
- WHAT?
THAT [bleep] LAY YOU DOWN.
- HEY, BROTHER, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT FIGHT YOU WAS AT.
THAT [bleep] GOT
A COUPLE LICKS IN, SURE.
BUT PFFT, I WAS LIKE, BIP!
[laughter]
MAN, I PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX.
[both howling]
PUT THE PUSSY ON THE--
both: THE CHAIN WAX.
- I PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX.
all: I PUT THE PUSSY
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX?
- HMM?
- IS THAT A THING?
- WELL, YEAH. THAT--YEAH.
THAT'S A--THAT'S A THING.
- YEAH.
- YEAH, THAT'S SOMETHING.
- OKAY.
- YEAH, I PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX.
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- I SAID I PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- HE PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX.
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX.
- UH, PUSSY COMING IN.
THIS IS THE CHAIN WAX.
- HOLD UP.
[laughter]
HOLD UP.
I JUST, UM, GOOGLED
"PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX."
NO RESULTS.
- MAN, UM,
WHY ARE YOU GOOGLING?
- NO, I'M JUST SAYING.
"PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX,"
IT'S NOT AN EXPRESSION.
- YE--YEAH IT IS.
- YEAH, IT IS.
- YES, THANK YOU.
- IT'S SOMETHING, LEO.
- YEAH.
- WHAT IT--WHAT IT--
WHAT DOES IT MEAN THEN?
- WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANS.
- DO IT, DO IT.
- IT MEANS THAT...
IS THAT YOU PUT THE...
all: PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
[overlapping chatter]
- NOPE, NOPE.
both: PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- IT'S NOT--DON'T--
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX.
- ACTING LIKE Y'ALL KNOW
WHAT IT IS--
OKAY, HAVE EITHER
OF THE TWO OF YOU--
HAVE YOU EVER SAID THE WORDS
"PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX"
IN ANY CONTEXT?
- PFFT, US?
- PFFT.
HE--HE TALKING TO YOU.
- MAN--
- HE AIN'T TALKING TO ME.
- [exhales]
- HEY, MAN.
IT'S NOT OUR FAULT
THAT YOU AIN'T NEVER PUT THE...
all: PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
[all cheering]
- PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- NO ONE CAN PUT THE PUSSY
ON THE CHAIN WAX
'CAUSE PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX
AIN'T A THING!
YOU TRYING TO START A THING,
AREN'T YOU?
- WHA--ME--
[laughs]
I MEAN, WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT, TRYING TO START A THING?
- A THING,
LIKE "OFF THE HOOK"
OR "I'MA PUT YOU ON BLAST."
YOU TRYING TO GET IT
IN THE ETHER,
SO EVERYBODY OUT THERE SAYING
"PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX."
- MAN, WHY ARE YOU
DOING THIS?
WHY YOU LOOKING UP
[bleep] I'M SAYING AND--
AND FACT-CHECKING MY ASS
AND [bleep]?
- YOU KEEP SAYING SOME [bleep]
THAT DOESN'T EXIST,
AND YOU GOT THING ONE
AND THING TWO
CORROBORATING YOUR STORY
LIKE IT DOES,
AND THEN--
WHY YOU LYING THEN?
IT'S BULL[bleep]!
- BODIE...
WHY DO YOU CARE SO MUCH
WHETHER I MADE UP
"PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX" OR NOT?
I LOST MY JOB.
MY GIRL LEFT ME.
AND ALL I W--
ALL I WANTED TO DO
WAS HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF FUN
WITH MY FRIENDS TODAY.
SO WHY--WHY DO YOU HA--
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO BELITTLE ME
LIKE THAT?
- [sighs]
IT'S JUST THAT I--
- YEAH?
- I'M JUST TRYING TO SAY--
- WHAT YOU TRYING TO SAY,
[bleep]?
- I'M TRYING TO SAY
THAT I WANT
TO PUT THE PUSSY...
all: ON THE CHAIN WAX!
[laughter]
- HE DID IT, YO.
HE PUT THE...
all: PUSSY ON THE CHAIN WAX!
- YEAH!